[Musique]
bienvenue quartier nicolas c'est ici
chez sa maman que marie marguerite
voyait prépare ses sorbets pays là ils
sont vingt closely moon saint-esprit
karkouri goûter anti doucet coco
pistache principe est on nous a les
joindre
marie marguerite voyait ça au fait mon
assassinat et aux malades sans qu'ils
m'ont la caf ainsi que iaquinta
ou même rester sur des publicités un
tissu local donc au match de gala pour
mettez vous savez
[Musique]
comment c'est des films académiques dans
votre petit comme mahmoud kabil dix ans
donc les commentaires y entame en a sans
doute aidé mais c'est moi et m'a dit
quand on connaît pas à penser que même
si nos témoins il y aura oublié parce
que c'est quand même une personnalité
entre guillemets parce que par leur
gentillesse qu'il y ait par manioc de
philippe billy
vous réparez sur beaucoup de sites et
ans alors je ferai de lait sucre et de
lait non sucré et de ce que chacun a sa
propre popularité est là qui sont un peu
plus plus élaborés comme la recette du
sabot coco vous ajoute la can et citron
et d'arômes le
confie par hernanes sinon les opérations
savais que j ai socialement ferait pas
que je le fais vraiment avec conscience
je ne sais pas pour vous faire je veux
pas pour vendre le fait pourquoi vous
non satisfaits on n'a pas les mêmes
goûts de l'eau paris pousse
normalement et puis l'amour et puis
passion pour tous nos contrôles et de
magie et pousse au double vie
à dormir est équipé d'une tribu tir à
l'ancienne qu'il fallait tourner pendant
1 minute pouvoir avoir des glaces
aujourd'hui je me suis équipé d'une
traité en une semaine à glace qui dure
qui va tourner pendant 10 à 15 minutes
[Musique]
cela en fait allé aux cadets magali bon
ça va aider moins 300 décoiffer un euro
mais en gros donc et puis quand aux
fidji garantie connais pas déguster
caprio et pour l'homme car pompiers par
titre contre almagro
6-2
marguerite propose une quinzaine de
parfums les plus demandés reste coco
goyave et cacahuètes il a espéré que
lake hélas yom d'ici jeunesse pour 1000
lacs et ripon flambeau à où il y a bien
écouté mais c'est aussi le
moment pour passer à peine moment là